welcome to another of its game playing
hypnotic specter played him quite a
number of times recently hmm e6 yeah
maybe maybe give this this opening ago
color knots not too bad pretty healthy
opening so bit like this good rafter if
Y place III it's a bit like the semi
Slav semi Slav you move up and the
service lavas rather good opening for
black well it's a satisfactory opening
and with an extra temple no it's not too
shabby yeah but its launch is not
playing rare okay there's also on the
line with b3 and the fianchetto often
called the colored circuit taught after
this Johannes Sacher Torte the
Challenger for audits the wrong word the
participant in the first world
championship match sukkot or against
Steinitz the winner was the first
official world champion once in a while
you have under zoom in there and Paul
Murphy but the only really recognized
first world champion as Steinitz and he
he got this title by beating saga Todd
okay Bishop to d7
yeah maybe I can I want to play a form
at some point and maybe I should prevent
it no prepared not prevent I shouldn't
prevent my ideas I should prepare them
we have III form the idea and home this
is one of those wow moments yeah where
you can do that and in the semi sloth is
this a valid line okay and it is usually
answered by be five at the semi slaw the
idea being to after capturing on b-52
places r easy for us to 65 but then this
also disappointed once bishop situ and
then e for coming at least I hope while
this guy is really spending lots of time
even slower than me and that that's
something yeah this is so as mentioned a
well-known idea and this time is laughs
opening there on I'm not quite sure
maybe I have got rookie one extra
something but this is the general idea
again this castle a and it's it's simply
intending to open up as many lines as
possible both days like a bit like and
in them at the bank oh I but now the
king is not here so it's a it's a quite
quite quick on the on the queenside
should take here yeah why not actually
it's not the greatest place for the
night I need to get it to get the power
back 94 I can play Queen takes yeah well
even I Texas is good
nike yeah should I play I'm not sure
let's drop this back for us I'm not sure
about Bishop b2 because without the B
file is something designed for a rook in
this position taking if I want to make a
bit of pressure on the clock and I'm in
the rare situation to to actually be
ahead on the clock and try to play good
claim
Luke be one which one don't know this
one attending right see 595 getting at
least the bishops yeah that's nice nice
position may be 94 now could be it could
be an idea getting getting the bishops
bag okay but now maybe just back all the
way back threatening to preserve the
bishop oh it's not caring about this
kind of stuff yeah okay okay I
understand but ok with it it's nice for
white just keeping the bishop 95 at 95
coming f3 that's it's very good for
white we should be four or age for
something like that
now let's let's gain try to gain the
default night on d6 is sound quite an
annoyance and now i can push you for and
Bishop d3 very nice but how to increase
the pressure now we this one threatening
a five I am NOT threatening you five
years 97
yeah this probably didn't really help
but it's still an excellent position his
king is cut off and I've got great great
player the Bishop's just take it we are
probably my deaf five coming
yeah picking up the pieces no night just
back problem 94 e 7 as the threat oh
wait while I do i do I allow him to
promote himself it's a yeah it doesn't
matter fortunately could have could have
taken care of that you look like a
pretty good game once in a while I even
like my own play and dad look look quite
nice actually here this was flowing very
naturally look so like terrible with the
bishops the center it says it's
excellent probably needs to do something
else earlier I thought just taking
actually and now I know if I for some
it's not so bad I mean ok the king but
it's it's not like I'm directly meeting
him more or anything this looks ok and
he is getting rid of the two bishops
really should do that pro I think this
is I know I I much prefer white at least
I'm of course um a well-known um fan of
the bishops but still yeah I should have
taken I think thanks for watching